sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten technik schmieden
der welt
die speerspitzen menschlicher
ingenieurskunst
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute weges gefährlich
verseucht
[Musik]
beim wettlauf ins all blieb nichts
unversucht
ausgemusterte schiffs kanonen sollten
die weltraumforschung der amerikaner vor
anderen
bei raumfahrttechnik denkt man immer
gleich an moderne raketen die in sile
rasen im grunde kann man aber auch eine
riesige kanonen abfeuern und damit das
gleiche erreichen
[Musik]
in dieser geheimen versuchsanstalt haben
die nazis ihre legendäre v2 rakete
entwickelt und damit den grundstein für
ein neues zeitalter gelegt
die anfänge der raumfahrt waren vom
krieg überschattet es ging nicht darum
menschen auf den mond zu bringen sondern
um militärische ziele
warum ist eine verlassene anlage in der
wüste arizonas für manche die wiege der
amerikanischen raumfahrt
[Musik]
sie haben echte pionierarbeit geleistet
forschung zum wohle der menschheit
und was hat ein ausrangiertes ölfass mit
dem kalten krieg und einem leben in der
schwerelosigkeit zu tun
[Musik]
man setzte affen in die raumkapsel und
schickte sie ins all
[Musik]
seit jahrhunderten beobachten die
menschen gewandt den sternenhimmel und
suchen nach erklärungen für den lauf der
gestirne
doch viele fragen blieben unbeantwortet
[Musik]
erst durch den technologischen
fortschritt im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
haben wir die erdanziehung überwunden
und neue antworten gefunden
[Musik]
die erste weltraumrakete die berüchtigte
v2 wurde in den 30er und 40er jahren in
peenemünde auf der ostseeinsel usedom
entwickelt
[Musik]
nur wenige meter vom strand entfernt
hinter kiefern verborgen finden sich
ruinen aus beton und stahl
es sind die überreste einer einst streng
geheimen militärischen anlage im dritten
reich genannt prüfstand 7
philipp baumann leitet das historisch
technische museum peenemünde und hat die
geschichte dieser geheimnisumwitterten
anlage erforscht
peenemünde horster first in peenemünde
war das erste professionelle
raketenprogramm deutschlands und der
welt beheimatet die erforschung des alls
war ein kernaspekt der nazi ideologie
[Musik]
die ingenieure die hier arbeiteten waren
nationalistisch und militaristisch
gesinnt sie hatten kein problem damit
deutschland zu dienen als sie hier
mächtige waffen erschufen
die regierung hat das programm
bereitwillig finanziert denn es ging ja
um die militärische vorherrschaft in
europa dank dieser gelder und durch
zielstrebige forschung hat die
raketentechnik schnell große
fortschritte gemacht innerhalb weniger
jahre etwas wie die v2 zu erschaffen war
phänomenal
der ingenieur werner vom raum ist in dem
30er jahren ein gefragter raketen
fachmann als technischer direktor der
heeresversuchsanstalt peenemünde wird er
mit der entwicklung raketen getriebener
waffen betraut
wernher von braun war der führende
raketen ingenieur zusammen mit seinen
kollegen stand er vor einer
technologischen herausforderung und die
wollten sie meistern
er war getrieben von der idee die
raketenwissenschaft für die erforschung
des alls nutzbar zu machen das ist ihm
zwar während der kriegsjahre nicht
gelungen aber nachdem er in die usa
gegangen war bildete seine forschung die
grundlage für das apollo programm und
die mondflüge in den 60er und 70er
jahren
[Musik]
von braun hat die volle unterstützung
des militärs als hitler an die macht
kommt startet sein raketenprogramm voll
durch
1936 beginnen die bauarbeiten an der
heeresversuchsanstalt peenemünde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es entsteht auch eine spezielle
abschussrampe von der aus testraketen in
die seichten gewässer der ostsee
abgefeuert und wieder geborgen werden
können
der name prüfstand 7
[Applaus]
der erdwall zieht sich einmal komplett
um den stadtweit stand und bildet die
sogenannte arena
genau hier wurden die raketen gestartet
[Musik]
insgesamt wurden über 300 raketen
abgefeuert man glaubte damals hier
draußen würde das niemand mitbekommen
enttarnt
worden war
b
germans bei morgenstern
wandern
im oktober 1942 wird eine so genannte a
4 rakete kurz für aggregat 4 erstmals
erfolgreich gestartet die berüchtigte
vergeltungswaffe v2
[Musik]
die rakete fliegt 84 einhalb kilometer
hoch und macht das potenzial der
technologie deutlich mit 14 metern höhe
und einem durchmesser von nur gut
anderthalb metern wiegt die v2 über 13
tonnen allein der sprengkopf wiegt eine
tonne
die 42 ist schon eine ziemlich
beeindruckende waffe und sie hat nicht
zuletzt den grundstein für die
mondlandungen und die gesamte
raketentechnik gelegt
aber dazu gehört auch die ganze
infrastruktur die anlagen die den
deutschen all das erst ermöglicht haben
die rakete aufzutanken den treibstoff
dafür herzustellen die logistik um alles
was man brauchte zu beschaffen die
ganzen überwachungssysteme und das ding
tatsächlich in die luft zu kriegen
[Musik]
aber hitler geht es weniger um die
erforschung des weltalls er will waffen
die neuen groß raketen sollen die
alliierten in die knie zwingen aber sie
sind noch lange nicht ausgereift
[Musik]
die raketen haben nie wirklich gut
funktioniert anfangs war das
waffensystem noch unausgegoren
[Musik]
die geschichte ihrer testflüge und
einsätze ist eine geschichte voller
explosionen und pannen
die v2 wurde entwickelt und getestet
während die deutschen krieg gegen die
alliierten führten sie diente also einem
fürchterlichen zweck
aber die ingenieursleistung dahinter
hatte hand und fuß das war sehr
beeindruckend
[Musik]
im juni 1944 stößt eine von prüft an
sieben abgefeuerte v2 in den weltraum
vor
sie fliegt über 170 kilometer hoch gott
sozusagen darauf regnen von brauns
raketen mit fast 4 facher
schallgeschwindigkeit auf london und
antwerpen nieder
[Musik]
aber selbst ihre mächtige
zerstörungskraft reicht nicht aus um den
krieg zu gunsten der deutschen zu
entscheiden
hitler war besessen von seinen
wunderwaffen und pumpte alles geld da
rein für die usa und die alliierten war
das ein vorteil denn dadurch fehlte das
geld anderswo es gab zu wenig panzer die
leute mussten fahrradfahren und die
ausrüstung auf dem schlachtfeld war
alles andere als modern was für eine
ironie
[Musik]
am ende wirken hitlers truppen
vernichtend geschlagen und viele v zwei
abschussrampen wie prüften 7 zerstört
[Musik]
die technologien lebt jedoch weiter
deutsche wissenschaftler wie vom baum
wechsel nach dem zweiten weltkrieg die
seiten und setzen ihr geheimnis raketen
wissen im dienste der usa ein
in der wüste in mexikos errichtet die us
armee auf dem white sands testgelände
sogar eine v2 abschussbasis
den launch komplex vertieft
[Musik]
die knapp 23 meter hohe anlage steht
heute verlassen in der wüste gezeichnet
vom flugsand doch einst war einst
ausgangspunkt für die reise ins weltall
[Musik]
ursprünglich ging es beim
raumfahrtprogramm nicht darum menschen
auf den mond zu bringen die ziele waren
militärischer natur man wollte
flugkörper ins all schicken egal wohin
nur um zu sehen wie sie wieder
runterkommen und ob man daraus
erkenntnisse ableiten konnte um den
feind anzugreifen
das waren die anfänge der raumfahrt
[Musik]
am ende des krieges gab es eine reihe
von visionären die verstanden hatten das
wissen der schlüssel zu einer
erfolgreichen zukunft ist der schlüssel
zum überleben in einer nuklearen welt
wer auf dem gebiet der raketen oder
atomwaffen technik zurück fällt könnte
untergehen
am 16 juli 1945 zünden forscher in white
sands die erste atombombe der geschichte
der kernwaffentest findet auf einem
abgelegenen teil des geländes statt
keine drei wochen vor dem abwurf der
hiroshima bombe nur wenige wochen zuvor
war mit dem bau des streng geheimen
websense proving ground begonnen haben
die usa wollen sich für einen möglichen
atomkrieg mit der sowjetunion wappnen
und die raketenforschung intensivieren
ihre
bisherigen entwürfe können den deutschen
v2 raketen nicht das wasser reichen die
usa stehen enorm unter druck
der rekord ist direktor des white sands
missile range museum er hat die anfänge
dieser streng geheimen forschungen
untersucht
verglichen mit den ersten amerikanischen
raketen war die v2 technologisch um
längen besser
das us pendant konnte gerade mal 16
kilogramm nutzlast 100 kilometer hoch in
die atmosphäre befördern die v2 schaffte
über 170 kilometer mit einer tonne
sprengung
[Musik]
damals war das alles streng geheim die
russen sollten keinesfalls erfahren was
die usa über raketen und ballistische
flugkörper wussten
neben waggons voller raketen bauteile
treffen in lizenz auch dutzende deutsche
wissenschaftler ein die an v2 programm
gearbeitet hatten
[Musik]
doch die wichtigste komponente des
raketenprogramms ist nicht irgendein
bauteil sondern wernher von braun der
vater der v2
aber ist der umstrittene wissenschaftler
hinter hitlers wunderwaffe wirklich der
richtige mann um den usa zu helfen
wernher von braun war der leiter des
deutschen raketenprogramms er hatte
ausgetüftelt wie man städte rund um den
globus attackieren konnte
als er dann die seiten wechselte und in
die usa ging stürzte er sich mit vollem
einsatz in deren programm ohne seine
hilfe hätte es jahrzehnte gedauert
solche fortschritte zu machen ohne ihn
hätten sie ihren rückstand vielleicht
niemals aufgeholt hat
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass von raul ein
glühender nazi war sondern dass er die
v2 in erster linie entwickelt hat weil
er eben ein mann war der raketen erfand
amerika hatte nun alle voraussetzungen
für ein erfolgreiches raketenprogramm
die raketen von denen sie lernen konnten
die sie nachbauen und analysieren
konnten und die expertise der deutschen
raketen ingenieure
die erfahrungen des deutschen v2
programms haben gezeigt dass die
technologie noch lange nicht ausgereift
ist
die us army baut deshalb einen riesigen
bunker um die starts von sicheren posten
aus überwachen zu können
seine fast acht meter dicke verstärkte
betondecke ist stark genug eine v2
explosion in 100 metern entfernung zu
überstehen
und selbst einem einschlag aus 170
kilometern höhe
[Musik]
der bunker wurde wegen der enormen
sprengkraft der v2 gebaut sie fasste
rund achteinhalb tonnen treibstoff also
eine sehr explosive ladung
das konnte man ja bei verschiedenen
fehlversuchen an der startrampe sehen
flog ein tank in die luft ging der
nächste mit hoch und es gab eine
gigantische explosion
die gut drei meter dicken betonwände
sollten die menschen im gebäude schützen
die leute in diesem raum waren
unverzichtbar für den erfolg des
programms steuerungs experten kontroll
und verbrennungs experten und die
militärischen kommandanten der anlage
während der stars der gesamte
expertenstab des v2 programms in diesem
bunker
[Musik]
zunächst scheint es als habe sich die
armee zu recht für die katastrophe
gewappnet
im april 1946 wird die erste for 2
rakete in amerika abgefeuert und
erreicht nur eine höhe von fünfeinhalb
kilometer bevor sie abstürzt und
explodiert
alle hoffnungen nun auf dem nächsten
start einige wochen später und dieses
mal fliegt die rakete 112 km hoch bevor
sie knapp 60 kilometer entfernt wieder
herunterkommt
[Musik]
der erste erfolgreiche start einer
großrakete auf amerikanischem boden er
läutet den beginn des weltraum
zeitalters in den usa ein
diese frühen für zwei starts in lizenz
hätte ich gerne selbst miterlebt das
muss eine aufregende zeit gewesen sein
wie sich das angefühlt haben muss für
ingenieure und wissenschaftler wie mich
plötzlich mit diesen wahnsinns raketen
ins all vorzudringen so vieles war noch
unerforscht und unbekannt man wollte die
sterne und die planeten beobachten
ungestört von der erdatmosphäre
je weiter die versuche am launch komplex
fertig voranschreiten umso deutlicher
wird dass die bisherige infrastruktur
nicht ausreicht eine völlig neue anlage
muss her um die v2 in die richtige stadt
position zu bringen eine die wenig
später standard an allen raketenabschuss
plätzen werden soll
bei den frühen v2 abschlüssen wurde die
rakete auf einem leiterwagen hergebracht
dem ursprünglichen deutschen
transportwagen dann wurde sie auf dem
statisch aufgerichtet und mit hilfe
mehrerer kleiner leitern betankt
vorbereitet und mit messinstrumenten
versehen
das problem war dass viele der
instrumente seit 1947 komplexer geworden
waren und es länger dauerte sie zu
installieren
also musste etwas solideres her ein
montage turm der 1947 aus kalifornien
kam er war auf schienen montiert man für
ihn heran klappte die stege runter
erledigte die arbeiten an der rakete
klappte dann die stege wieder hoch vor
den turm weg und feuerte das ding ab
[Musik]
in websense experimentiert man nicht nur
mit raketen technologien von dort
schicken forscher erstmals lebewesen in
die atmosphäre
lebendige affen
[Musik]
mediation in space im laufe der zeit
wurden mit den v2 raketen immer mehr
strahlungs tests durchgeführt anfangs
testet man die auswirkungen der
strahlung auf eine ameise eine
fruchtfliege oder ein maiskorn
bis man dann irgendwann affen in eine
kapsel setzte und sie ins all schickte
heutzutage würden tierschützer völlig
zurecht sturm laufen aber damals scherte
es niemanden keiner wusste das problem
war dass die affen nicht überlebt die
falschen technik war damals noch nicht
so weit dass die kapsel sicher wieder
zur erde schweben konnte also starben
sie
anfang der 50er jahre hat die forschung
in websense enorme fortschritte gemacht
und die grundlage für weitere
entwicklungen geschaffen
die v2 stößt an ihre grenzen
aber die wissenschaftler und ingenieure
des launchs komplex fertig sway haben
mit ihren erkenntnissen anderen
forschern den weg geebnet
die frühen raketenstarts in white sands
stehen ein bisschen im schatten der
überragenden erfolge der apollo-mission
aber diese frühen projekte waren extrem
wichtig
[Musik]
nach dem ende des v 2 programms ging es
vor allem darum schneller als die
sowjets im alt zu sein aber das war
alles neuland niemand in den usa hatte
bis dahin mit so großen flüssigkeit
raketen gearbeitet
die forschung hier diente dem wohle der
menschheit und das war damals sicher der
hauptantrieb der wissenschaftler
die v2 mark als kriegswaffe nicht die
erwartungen der nazis erfüllt haben doch
sie ist das erste menschengemachte
objekt das den weltraum erreicht hat
[Musik]
während ingenieure an standorten wie
websense kontinuierlich an raketen
weiter tüfteln führt man in der bar
kreft forschungsstation im
kalifornischen white mountains weitere
versuche an affen durch die forscher
wollen herausfinden wie sich die
raumfahrt auf die tiere auswirkt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es waren die 60er jahre der summer of
love wie viele amerikaner haben da wohl
mitbekommen dass man affen auf einen
berg brachte und versuche mit ihnen
machte um beim raumfahrtprogramm die
nase vorn zu haben
wäre das weithin bekannt gewesen hätte
es sicher einen riesen aufschrei gegeben
mit tieren zu arbeiten war leider eine
wichtige vorstufe für die bemannte
raumfahrt
diese experimente waren einfach
notwendig und natürlich kam dabei tiere
ums leben mit menschen hätte man das
nicht machen können das wäre dann
womöglich das ende des gesamten
raumfahrtprogramms gewesen
[Musik]
anfang der 50er jahre ist die bar
kraftstation eine streng geheime
forschungseinrichtung der us navy
als sie geschlossen werden soll
übernimmt die university of california
den standort mit unterstützung der nase
und dank einer einzigartigen opfer von
schimpansen wird bar croft eine tragende
säule des amerikanischen
raumfahrtprogramms
der historiker daniel pritschet kennt
die umstrittene geschichte von warcraft
dieser bau stammt von 1951 damals wurden
hier meteorologische daten gesammelt und
labor tiere aufgezogen
es ging darum die physiologie der
schimpansen zu erforschen denn die
sollten wir vor den menschen ins all
geschickt werden außerdem haben die
wissenschaftler instrumente entwickelt
um den gesundheitszustand der affen
während ihres weltraum trips zu
kontrollieren
[Musik]
man gewinnt wertvolle erkenntnisse wenn
man tiere simulierten
weltraumbedingungen aussetzt
kontrollierte versuche am boden sind
viel effizienter als reihenweise teure
raketen ins all zu schicken deren daten
man vielleicht gar nicht auswerten kann
man kann die auswirkungen extremer
beschleunigungskräfte an tieren testen
man kann auch die folgen harter
landungen an tieren testen und genau das
haben sie getan man hatte zwar
erkenntnisse darüber wie sich große
höher auf den menschen auswirkt aber
damals wusste man noch nicht was bei
schwerelosigkeit mit dem menschlichen
körper passiert so was konnte man an
tieren testen und das ist ja auch
naheliegender als sofort an menschen
herum zu experimentieren
[Musik]
das ist ein original relikt aus den
frühen sechzigern
aus der zeit als schimpansen und macken
auf weltraumflüge vorbereitet wurden
das hier ist ein 200 liter fass mit
einem kleinen plexiglas sitz es soll
eine weltraumkapsel simulieren
es ist von außen gedämmt und mit
kathetern ausgestattet die den tieren
implantiert wurden
darin haben sie sich auf ihre reise ins
all vorbereitet
die kleinen kapseln mitsamt den
schimpansen darin wurden an einem
helikopter befestigt und zur bahre croft
station geflogen
das war der beginn einer langen reihe
von versuchen um die körperlichen
reaktionen der tiere auf stress und
druckveränderungen zu erforschen
[Musik]
wir sind hier im erdgeschoss der bar
croft station
in den 60er jahren wurden wir viele
tiere gehalten vor allem schimpansen und
markanten
man wollte ihre physiologie studieren
und hatte dafür telemetrische
vorrichtungen entwickelt um ihren
körperlichen zustand aus der ferne zu
überwachen
hier konnte man auch die auswirkungen
großer höhe auf ihre gesundheit
erforschen so bekamen sie eine art
ausbildung und gewöhnten sich an ihre
kleinen sitze denn sie sollten ihr
später in engen welt raumkapsel ins all
fliegen
die amerikaner trainierten die tiere das
zu tun was auch menschen im all machen
würden knöpfe drücken hebel ziehen und
so weiter dabei gewannen sie
erkenntnisse die beim design der kapsel
halfen die letztlich menschen ins all
bringen sollte
verschiedene länder schickten
verschiedene tiere hoch mal aus mehr mal
weniger nachvollziehbaren gründen wusste
man zum beispiel dass die tiere nicht
zurückkommen würden setzte man eher
mäuse oder ähnliches 1 aber natürlich
wollte man auch versuchen mit größeren
tieren durchführen die sowjets schicken
mit sputnik 2 die hündin like einzahlen
sie setzten für ihr programm
straßenhunde ein also tiere die an ein
hartes leben ohne ausreichend futter und
wasser gewöhnt waren sie glaubten dass
die geeigneter seien für die versuche
die sie durchführen wollten
man kann temperaturschwankungen
simulieren und menschen in zentrifugen
extremer beschleunigung aussetzen wie
bei einem raketenstart aber es gibt
grenzen
das ist noch heute so darum führen die
experimente auf der internationalen
raumstation durch auch astronauten sind
so gesehen versuchskaninchen
wir erforschen immer noch wie der
menschliche körper auf schwerelosigkeit
oder auf kosmische strahlung reagiert da
gibt es noch viel zu lernen
schon seit den ersten v2 testflügen in
new mexico haben wissenschaftler auch an
menschen erforscht ob eine bemannte
raumfahrt möglich ist
bis 31
[Musik]
1961 fliegt der sowjetische kosmonaut
juri gagarin an bord der wostok 1 als
erster mensch ins all die usa stehen
jetzt unter zugzwang
[Musik]
sie gehen neue wege um nicht noch mehr
ins hintertreffen zu geraten eine der
wichtigsten und größten
forschungsanlagen der us army ist der
riesige yuma proving ground in arizona
[Musik]
verloren in der wüste steht dort ein
riesiges geschützt die legendäre hard
hochgeschwindigkeits kanone
jahrzehntelang war sie in vergessenheit
geraten doch jetzt ist ihre
schlüsselrolle in der weltraumforschung
wieder in den fokus gerückt
bei raumfahrttechnik denkt man immer
gleich an moderne raketen die inside
raten aber
offenbar kann man auch auf
jahrhundertealte technologien
zurückgreifen
die kanone einfach mit einer riesigen
kanone in den himmel feuern
dinge mit kanonen in die erdumlaufbahn
zu befördern ist gar nicht so dumm das
ist eine billige und zuverlässige
methode
die kanone ist in den 60ern das
kernstück einer versuchsreihe namens
high altitude research project kurzhaar
das projekt geht zurück auf den
kanadischen ballistik expertenjury der
mit hilfe des geschäftsjahres dinge ins
all befördern will
für mich war okay es war einfach ein
genie er war voll blut ingenieure und
wissenschaftler und hatte immer
irgendwelche versuche laufen
als er anfing kanonen für super vitale
und orbitale flüge zu testen haben viele
leute witze gemacht über seine jules
verne kanone
andere sagten das wäre nur sinnvoll wenn
man messinstrumente die daten zur erde
senden bulle hat sie alle eines besseren
belehrt
für ihn waren super kanonen ein
kostengünstiger weg ins all sein
programm brachte viele erkenntnisse bull
will mit seinem kanonen in die
ionosphäre vordringen diese schicht aus
elektrisch geladener luft ist wichtig
für den globalen funkverkehr da sie kurz
wellen reflektiert
zudem kann sie die flugbahn von
raumfahrzeugen beeinträchtigen
[Musik]
zu kohls zeiten sind raketen extrem
teuer und unzuverlässig er hofft dass
seine technologie weltraumforschung zu
low budget preisen möglich macht
[Musik]
wenn man das an erforschen will ohne
eine teure rakete hoch zu schicken und
stattdessen ein paar billige sensoren
abfeuern kann um herauszufinden was ich
da oben abspielt dann kann man auch auf
diese weise wertvolle daten gewinnen
keine frage
als die usa red bulls haben projekt
einstiegen hatte das für sie zwei
vorteile einerseits sammelten sie viele
informationen über die obere atmosphäre
andererseits haben sie sich einen
entscheidenden militärischen vorteil
verschafft von da an konnten sie
flugkörper rund um den erdball direkt
auf den feind feuern und darum ging es
ihnen eigentlich
es war wichtig beide technologien zu
haben denn das weltraum zeitalter
steckte er noch in den kinderschuhen
nach dem ende des zweiten weltkriegs
eröffnete die technologie völlig neue
möglichkeit sie und da man nicht wusste
welche funktioniert verfolgte man zwei
ansätze gleichzeitig raketen und große
kanone
[Musik]
heute steht die harp weltraum kanone
einsam und verlassen in der wüste
arizona doch für die forschung ist sie
noch immer interessant
vinci das geschütz experte am yuma
testgelände beschäftigt sich mit der
geschichte und konstruktion der rekord
waffe
[Musik]
für das programm wurden 240 cm chips
geschütz rohre verwendet eines 21 meter
lang das andere ungefähr 15 sie wurden
zusammen gefügt und eine tragende
struktur um sie herum gebaut hier hinten
bei den bolzen wurden die zwei teile
zusammen geschweißt das äußere gestänge
sollte sie stabil halten und verhindern
dass das ganze auseinanderfällt
wenn man so eine kanone aufrichtet und
abfeuert wirken große kräfte und man
wollte nicht dass eines der rohre sich
aus der verankerung gelöst
die lafette der vulkan ohne wird eigens
entworfen um einen abschuss im 85 grad
winkel zu ermöglichen
[Musik]
die erste kann ohne wird 1963 auf der
insel barbados aufgestellt unweit des
äquators
von hier aus schießt sie projekte in die
atmosphäre die dann aus dem meer
geborgen werden können
heimatforscher
wie die inselbewohner auf die riesige
kanone reagiert haben die noch heute
nahe der küste vor sich hin rostet
von 1962 bis in die 70er jahre hinein
wurde die kanone über 2000 mal
abgefeuert das waren viele heftige
überschallknall
die bavaria konnten jeden knall von hier
bis hoch zum gipfel der insel spüren der
halver enorm häuser wurden in ihren
fundamenten erschüttert einige bekam
sogar risse trotzdem fanden die meisten
dass das alles gut für die insel war es
hat barbados weltweit prestige
eingebracht und ihm praktisch einen
höhenflug beschert
[Musik]
um etwas ins all zu befördern braucht
man offenbar keine raketenwissenschaft
die halb kanone zeigt dass das auch
einfacher geht
das war fast schon primitive technologie
die bis an ihre grenzen getrieben wurde
um ein projektil kerzengerade 180
kilometer weit in die atmosphäre zu
schießen
neben den vorteilen hat der einsatz der
riesen geschütze auch schwierigkeiten
mit sich gebracht um etwas in großer
höhe zu schießen muss man es sehr stark
beschleunigen und unter umständen halten
die gerätschaften den g kräften nicht
stand auch die masse ist ein thema denn
sehr schwere dinge kann man mit dieser
technik nicht abfeuern man muss sich
also auf kleine objekte beschränken
wolle entwirft ein neuartiges förmiges
projektil das informationen in den
oberen atmosphärenschichten sammeln soll
das sogenannte market ist ummantelt von
einem tribe spiegel eine technologie die
schon im zweiten weltkrieg bei panzer
abwehr granaten zum einsatz kam
das smart ed ist aerodynamik geformt und
sieht aus wie ein großer teil mit finden
der treibt spiegel füllt den hohlraum im
kanonen lauf in diesem fall bestand aus
drei sogenannten panels aus einfachem
sperrholz die gase trieben das ganze aus
dem geschütz rohr und die paddles führen
hat in der projektilspitze steckten
messinstrumente und am hinteren ende
konnten dinge abgeworfen werden je nach
versuchsreihe
da steckt viel ingenieurskunst drin aber
was mir besonders gefällt ist wie diese
mischung aus primitiver und moderner
technologie alle rekorde bricht ein
projekt hier in solche höhen zu schießen
um die marge bis in die ionosphäre zu
feiern bedarf es gigantische mengen
treibstoff bei jedem abschuss wirken
enorme kräfte auf die harp kanone
[Musik]
man sieht hier den massiven
schraubverschluss der das geschütz fuhr
nach hinten abschließt und den rückstoß
aufhängt die länge lässt erahnen was für
ladungen da reinpassen und was für ein
druck beim abfeuern entstand bei einigen
tests lage bei über 300 millionen newton
pro quadratmeter
du musst die richtigen materialien
wählen das ausmaß der explosion durch
den eingesetzten treibstoff errechnen du
muss sicherstellen dass der rückstoß die
kanone nicht zerreißt und dass der lauf
lang genug ist um etwas derart hoch zu
feuern dahinter stecken sehr viele
überlegungen und technische expertise
aber
im kern ist es sehr primitiv aufgebaut
und das gefällt mir
nach den erfolgreichen testreihen auf
barbados richtet die us army eine
weitere hat kann ohne auf dem
testgelände ein und dort stellte red
bull einen rekord auf der noch heute
bestand hat am 18 november
1966 feierte kann ohne ein blatt ab dass
bei einer mündungsgebiet ich kai von
über 3600 metern pro sekunde fast 180
kilometer hoch fliegt
[Musik]
das geschütz steht immer noch in der
wüste von arizona gut gefühlt und
allzeit bereit die sterne wieder ins
visier zu nehmen
in der kraftstation werden bis heute die
auswirkungen großer höhe auf lebewesen
erforscht allerdings ohne versuche einen
schimpansen vorzunehmen
die moderne raketentechnologie hat die
v2 längst überflügelt und
historische standorte wie prüfstand 7
oder der lounge komplex fertig wurden
stillgelegt die weltraumforschung strebt
neuen horizonten entgegen
mittlerweile geht es auch immer darum
die kosten zu reduzieren
das klappt weil wir viele der
entwicklungen auch für alltagsprodukte
nutzen
spacex setzt auf wiederverwendbare
raketen das kann die kosten deutlich
senken
[Musik]
in zukunft werden wir in der
weltraumforschung vielleicht milliarden
in technologien investieren die wir
heute noch gar nicht kennen vielleicht
werden wir aber auch hier und da auf
einfache vielleicht sogar primitive
technologien zurückgreifen wie die harp
kanone
man wird sicher keine menschen per kann
ohne auf den mars schießen können aber
wenn es gelingt objekte in erdnahe
umlaufbahn zu transportieren sie dort
zusammen zu bauen um dann tiefer ins all
vorzustoßen und dort forschung zu
betreiben
das ist doch eine tolle vorstellung
eine kombination von verschiedenen
technologien aus verschiedenen technik
zeitaltern die etwas zustande bringt
dass wir uns heute noch gar nicht
vorstellen können